[Music]
joe biden won the presidential election
and even though i'm very excited about
that it's important to stay kind
and be a gracious winner i believe that
but trump has been responsible for
inciting racist violence
abhorrent border policies and hundreds
of thousands dying in a pandemic
i don't know if i can spare any good
wishes for him
but uh let me try
[Music]
i wish him help so we'd live a very long
life he'd live to see a divorce
from his 20th wife she'd bleed him dry
and he'd die penniless but
i don't wish him well
[Music]
i wish him laughter in times that he's
feeling tense
but it's always other people laughing at
his expense
and it hurts his big dumb feelings
but i don't wish him well
i hope he develops a misshapen
butt and can never find underwear
and every kid whoever sees them says hey
what's wrong with your derriere
they stare i wish him adventures in
life on the grandest scale more
specifically the kind that you'll find
in jail but
that won't be so bad cause that's where
all his friends are
but i don't wish him well
[Music]
i wish him hope in his heart that
replaces his rage he gets his ass beat
by kids that he kept
in a cage and they play that [ __ ] on
pay-per-view but i don't wish him well
[Music]
i hope every time he
introduces himself he says hi
i'm extremely slow
and every time he introduces himself
they reply i know they already know
i wish
his face
[Music]
i wish him understanding and deep
concern
for why people's hate for this man so
strongly burns
he'd repent change his ways but it would
be too late cause
i don't wish him well no i
know i don't
i don't wish him well
[Music]
you